Java was invented by a gentleman by the name of James Gosling at Sun. It was
originally called Oak, and it was intended for use with PDAs. Then when in
the 90s, there was a lot of interest in video on demand using the internet,
Sun thought that Java maybe the right
language for programming set-top boxes, but unfortunately the
cable TV industry went with SGIF for the
VOD trials, and so Oak fell flat at that
point. And Sun all but gave up on Oak then the World Wide Web caught on and Java
got a new life with the need for containment
of what happens on the client boxes connecting to
the World Wide Web. And today a lot of
internet e-commerce depend a lot on the Java framework.
The intent in this lesson is not to talk about
the Java language itself but the distributed object model of Java.